so how to how to get or how to create
this structured file for genomics
analysis you can take the raw first q
files and uh use the talbot bioinfo
platform to set up a an example a
pipeline or set up a pipeline that is
going to uh convert these fastq files
into a table of vcf files structured
data that we can employ for
visualization or further downstream
analysis let's go to uh let's cut cut
here and go to a demo pipeline or set up
a demo pipeline in the turbo bioinfo
platform so that we can get a taste of
how to
set up a
genomics
pipeline or genomics data
yeah pipeline in there it's stopped by
info platform and those who have um
credentials please log into server t bio
info
and when you log in you're going to get
a screen like this
and in this screen
please follow along as uh as you have
and if you are
if you uh have any
hiccups or if you feel any
necessity to
ask me to wait or proceed we can do that
and have an interactive session so
please
log into a server t bioinfo
platform and under
mutation variant and the parallel
analysis of mutation variant data so you
generally have uh
we generally have the collection of
different pipelines are setting up
different pipelines and algorithms for
different types of analysis as elia had
explained it to you so for several of
these analysis we have prepared uh what
we call as demo pipeline where users you
can get a uh get an experience of
setting up an analysis pipeline and uh
and uh understand how each and every
step that is involved in setting up this
pipeline is is being um incorporated
into this uh analysis in the into the
platform and you also get um access to
the
processed or structured data at the end
of setting up this demo pipeline which
you can download and perform your
analysis uh downstream analysis or
practice your analysis that you have
been learning in the
learnomics platform so let's let's go
here in the mutation variant analysis
and the mutation within data
section uh please click this
down arrow and then you have several
demo pipeline that has been
carefully constructed or carefully
designed for you so let's check one of
those
so you are going to get
experience of setting up setting up a
pipeline from various several different
options too so
in the demo pipeline and also in when
you are going to set up your own
pipeline um you get a
you get suggestions for
your next possible steps that you can do
or that you can perform within the
available uh data depending upon what
you have
selected for the previous step so since
this is a demo pipeline the necessary
files have already been uploaded and
they have been referenced so we started
and we start
and say okay and before selecting each
and every option you will get a
short
information window
of what that is going to what that
algorithm is going to perform for
example this algorithm is going to clean
up your pcr uh
amplification
duplicates and amplification biases and
you click ok and then you have several
of these uh
from several of these options now we
have only one option available for our
next logical step and um
yes omnia please
yeah
please share your
questions
you can share it in the chat chat box
also
i think you're still muted
that's okay so yeah so to go forward
let's click uh
next step in the pipeline where we are
going to after cleaning up the pcr
amplification artifacts we are going to
map these sequences or map these
shortlies onto the reference genome and
then we click ok and then our next
possible output is
our next possible
option for this pipeline or for this
setup is going is highlighted
as a
variant differential variant calling uh
algorithm so you click ok
and then you use somatic sniper
to compare the uh
variants that are calculated from two
different uh biological types then you
end the pipeline here
so once you end the pipeline
you get access to
yeah iman though in the same demo you
have more options uh i have more options
on your screen when you click some of
those options and if you do if you
follow
either of those options you are going to
get access to a different demo pipeline
one of them is going to be uh um a
visualization pipeline the other is
going to give you output like uh yeah
like this a tablet output like
pipeline so uh depending upon what you
have clicked so far you will get
different uh options and you'll get yeah
you you just try to click through uh
through them and understand what is uh
understand what yeah what is being
analyzed through the output uh files is
there a link of recording in this uh
demo
um
yes there are yeah there are uh
recordings that talks about these demo
pipeline and this ah
sonalika will share with you
where to find those recordings and
for the purpose of today's session let's
move forward so this is this is how you
can perform a genomics analysis and then
download the variant calling file since
this file is too big for
current and
for current session to complete download
let's move on to
to the powerpoint presentation
okay can you see the screen
i think yes so a similar omix data
another example for nomix data is
transcriptomics data so such data
transcriptomics data represents the mrna
expression which is one of the very good
way to analyze what is actually going on
inside the cell by observing active
transcription of protein coding genes
and
when
when we normally know that dna is first
transcript to rna and then rna is
translated to protein and depending upon
the conditions and the specific
conditions of the cell and the stress
that cell is undergoing these expression
of the protein will change and will be
characteristics to the phenotypical
condition of the cell or the sample that
we are analyzing
so ah
to to compare between genomics and
transcriptomics analysis uh
transcriptomics analysis is simply not a
subset of genomics analysis by leaving
out non-coding part uh protein coding
regions generally in in in the dna or
the genome contain large structures of
non-coding sequences called introns and
when these introns are spliced out
in rna transcripts then we will have a
different
splice forms for the same
gene being encoded or the same gene
being developed and depending upon the
condition depending upon the phenotype
of the cell some of these uh
splice forms will be expressed more
often than the other and this such an
analysis is going to help us understand
the state or help us understand the
biological condition of the cell or
will be extremely useful in um
performing a differential gene
expression analysis which is just going
to compare the expression levels of
cells
for example of
tumor cells and normal cells
so um how to set up such a pipeline we
can again go to uh the demo pipeline in
uh in the turbot bioinfo platform and we
will now for this analysis we will
download the data and see what is the
output data what does the output data
look like so um i will come back to the
setting up of this pipeline in in a bit
and
when you set up a transcriptomics
analysis pipeline as a result you will
obtain um a table of continuous numeric
data that is annotated by
gene id
and organized by samples in a given
experiment so your columns are going to
be different sample names and your rows
are going to be different gene ids given
in the form of ansible ids or given in
the form of transcriptions so the
intersection will actually tell you
the expression level for that particular
gene id and in that particular
transcript in that particular sample
so let's again go back to
server
bioinfo server and
set up a
pipeline for um
transcriptomics data analysis this time
we are going to download the data to
check or to
get a feel for how the transcriptomics
structure data
looks like and what we can do from that
or what we can learn from this data so
when you
go to server
server dot t bio info and um
in under the transcriptomics section uh
you can click this uh down arrow and
then click either of these projects to
um
to set up a demo pipeline let's click
the cell line project
and here also the input files necessary
fast queue files our input files are
already been
inputted and
and
the pipeline is already run and
completed and for the educational
purposes we have developed this demo
pipeline so that you can get a feeling
for
setting up this
transcriptomics analysis to know more
about different options or different
algorithms that are involved in these
different options of preprocessing
mapping onto genome or mapping onto
transcriptome and quantification of
these expression levels and differential
expression analysis and
other annotation analysis so you can
refer to that transcriptomics extensive
transcriptomics course or program ah
from where you can learn lot of
information yeah
a lot of information regarding the
choice of the algorithm and how to
use certain algorithms for certain data
sets that we have so let's start this
process again this is going to tell you
a very basic outline of how this rna-seq
analysis is going to be
performed so it involves pre-processing
mapping and quantification of expression
level at its basic uh level yes omnia i
think you have raised your hand please
uh
share your questions in the chat i'm
following the chat window all along so
after this you uh perform trimomatic
which is going to
clean or which is going to
trim out the
technical and adapter sequences that are
necessary for
identifying our samples in the pool of
samples that is being sequenced together
so let's click ok and brush through a
little bit
do pcr cleaning
and then we have an option uh now to uh
for example mapping on to genome or
mapping onto transcriptome transcript so
we will
now
select mapping on to transcript home
option but you can also very well select
isat2 which is going to map onto
genome process
so about i2 will map the reads onto the
transcriptome
and after this we get an uh get an
option or we get a highlight for
selecting the um
and selecting the expect
expression uh
quantification table from arson
so this is going to
use expectation maximization algorithm
to
count uh or to calculate or quantify the
expression levels of different genes and
then giving give give it to us in a
in a tabular format so let's click ok
and then we end this pipeline
and click ok
and
you get
yes
you get option to download demo pipeline
so from here you'll get several
different options for example you will
get
expression levels of all iso forms in
the cell lines and expression levels of
yeah and expression levels of all the
genes in the cell line and expression
levels of exon that are specific to
exons in this in this in this specific
uh sample and we also get these are all
absolute quantified quantified
expression levels and
we also get a link to uh normalized and
annotated expression level so you can
click these and download these results i
have already downloaded these and if you
are if you are following along with me
uh download these um download these
results and we will open those results
up in the excel and and
take a peek through what we can do with
these uh
with this output results so let's yeah
let me uh open up these files in excel
so let me share everything so that is
easy for you to follow
okay so i have downloaded this annotated
cell line and also the expression
of genes in the cell txt so let's
quickly
import these files into excel
to see how the structured data looks
like
yeah okay
can you see my screen i think it's still
visible let me make it a little bit
bigger so that it's not very small so as
i mentioned uh yes thank you as i
mentioned in the on the column you'll
have the sample types and on the rows
you will have the ensemble ids and you
you find um the raw counts for this exp
expression table all along here so if we
use or if i use
if i download the
annotated normalized and annotated
table let it open you can quickly see
the difference between these two tables
uh for example this is as
as
as it has been mentioned this is an
annotated table so what does this
annotation mean this annotation means
simply
the files are the samples are properly
annotated you see here
the samples are annotated by their
respective names instead of just
mentioning this as
the file names or the run information
file names of the fascia files and
their values are normalized now we can
see that their values are normalized
because we don't have values like
15 000 and 16 000 anymore
everything is between uh something yeah
roughly between less than 10 and they're
also negative values so they are
centered and normalized so when will you
use uh uh for example a data in in a
non-normalized format and data in a
normalized format so for the downstream
analysis uh like statistical analysis we
can prefer to use the normalized
data because
because most of the statistical
techniques that we are going to employ
will require some sort of or some form
of normalization at our end and even if
we do not use the normalization we have
to perform our own normalization